Roseanne you and her have been hanging
out I got it oh my God talk about
Thanksgiving
um when you are talking to Roseanne Bar
and making eye contact with this person
it is I I can't even describe it it's
just like holy crap rosean Bar's talking
to me she is I've said this to her face
pathologically funny like it does not
turn off and you're sitting there and
you're like holy crap and when you make
her laugh which is that laugh that's in
the theme song of her show you feel like
okay I did a Mitzvah I did something
good and right in the world that I made
Rosanne bar laugh um and it's also
really funny because and she's GNA hate
this because I tell her she's adorable
she doesn't like that she's little you
think of rosean bar as this like force
of nature like a tsunami she's like 53
I'd say like maybe 130 like and she's
and she puts on the sunglasses you think
this little old Jewish lady you'd never
know this is one of the most epic
performers of all time she lives near
here now so it's just so much fun
talking to her there was an old
satirical magazine in the I think like
uh early 2000s called hee written
written by Jews and she dressed up as
Hitler for one of the photo shoots and
she was baking little men in the oven I
got I found it on eBay I wanted her to
sign it to Michael it should have been
you yeah but she signed it to Michael
you're one smart cookie and now it hangs
love Mom rosenb bar and I call her mom
and it hangs over my uh desk cuz have
her like good domestic goddess energy
flowing at
me